welcome to this video i'm playing a
ashki international asha aaj ki side
NASA ok from from united arab emirates
yep I got this one right and we get an
Enzo let's see what precise line yeah it
looks like the hoop know by a
transposition ok now it's covering it
spoilsport maybe I should have taken
first ok it's not a big problem at all
it's just them it's ok for for for black
hair all this ok take and play d5 maybe
we get an isolated queen porn position
here what long castles in an IQ p
positioner that's that's cute ok ok make
sure that he gets like you p taking on
before I I don't really like but a 6b
five foot it's good for black normally
in any case so if he has cassard long it
should be a it should be should be M
especially good ok start with this come
on I wanted to play Bishop e7 but i can
wait for this until he plays it may be d
5 is a move that that you can try
maybe if I go night before here maybe d
is sick so I mean this is this is this
is probably okay now but there is this
system at least dangerous for the moment
because of the activity that right has
with Neji and then moves like that it's
probably not objectively working I mean
to be on long Castle this is a
completely wacky move that really
shouldn't work at all okay I'm a tech g5
with check him
lab that maybe h4 h4 intending night age
7 King age 7 h 5h was pretty much the
only move that has some chance of just
justifying what he did there should be
seven here
proved tough very tough position as
wacky as it is it is still still tough
to play we should be 7f I guess yeah he
can go on at age seven but one whatever
I probably need to I can I can consider
to to give up the exchange and play rook
c8 and before these kind of ideas
whoopsie am with the before idea
hmm Akeem takes h5 I don't really see
how this should ok I can give the check
on g5 then check on c3 and operate with
this idea of Bishop b4 somehow but I'm
still in a very awkward a very awkward
pina with age 5
okay come on let's do that I'm spending
far too much time against this stuff
should really pay click here ok this is
this is possible before channel
threatening to take on be to winning the
Queen yeah I cannot really tell you
what's going on here I needed to play
now one minute something now there this
Knight c3 being the the next next threat
check okay rook takes I guess getting
out of getting out of the tech here by
the night
yeah this is no 93 isn't this this quite
quite a lot here check check always
check check it's also route takes rook
shanks here with check so that's a bit
much I know I'm here I'm under some
threats as well but still and what can
you play key this year and then suddenly
wins for no reason time morning bishop
is six here I have no check in this
position which is really frustrating
unbelievable stuff again I can take and
click weenie six check in check Wow and
I can take d5 that's what a crazy game
now my white was white was of course
totally lost totally lost but I didn't
didn't find them the precise way to
punish him this is never ever we're
working for what never absolutely never
I know it tries to play fancy stuff I
love that they play really total
nonsense and then be cute about it could
have one much easier
yeah Queen f7 win snow yeah this also
does black resign yeah unbelievable ok
so now let's let's check how black wind
see a check check ok ok I need to take d
1 first jack this is just unbelievable
just under you I just need to take here
first and then she just over of course I
just this is just mindless yeah my play
here just mindless I was thinking okay
rook f2 and and it simply didn't
calculate even one move further that
after king and one I don't have a check
hmm just this check and he has
absolutely nothing takes rook takes
check King somewhere bishop t5 and
resigns why does just down everything
and this is the logical consequence of
this totally wacky setup long castles in
the iqp position it's just completely
nonsense like it's better in many ways
yeah can also play g 6 cm and so on meds
are just annoying to lose against such
such crazy plane which is not not really
lacking at all check I just need to take
you one look ever to us is just a
district after this I had don't have a
check yeah and this is just fancy play
what i meant i can he can just take here
and and it's over I have no reply of
whatsoever against this okay whoo okay
well thanks for watching